we may not be used to thinking ourselves
in these terms but the labels romantic
and classical usefully bring into focus
some of the central themes of our
personalities and help us to gain a
clearer sense of who we and other people
are these are some of the things that
divide romantic from classical
personalities romantics relish things
that seem slightly to defy rational
explanations they're enthusiastic about
feelings and wary of the intellect as a
guide to life they believe one shouldn't
always think too much in their eyes it
may be slightly unfair to probe a
decision or a mood too hard they like
instinct in particular they think one
shouldn't always attempt to take apart
emotions classicists on the other hand a
weary of intuition they've learnt often
through bitter experience how misguided
and deluded their own feelings may be
and hence look rather skeptically and
caustically upon them romantics are wary
of teaching and instruction they think
things should be spontaneous rather than
taught the idea that people might need
to think rationally and exhaustively
about what career to choose for
themselves or whom they should marry
strikes the romantic as a misguided
intrusion of Education into things which
should be spontaneous and natural they
like the notion of a calling and of love
at first sight part of romantics respect
for spontaneity leads them to look with
particular interest at children who seem
to them to have more direct access to
the kinds of truths and sensibilities
that adults have lost to the romantic it
will always be a child who points out
that the Emperor is wearing no clothes
those of a classical temperament don't
necessarily respect the current
education system as we know it but the
abstract idea of education seems to them
very important they believe that
training is vital if we're to avoid
making too many mistakes in our
emotional or professional lives the
Romantic person is devoted to saying
what they think or feel they're allergic
to the idea of being fake or of having
secrets authenticity is vital but
classical person Revere's politeness as
a very important lid that suppresses
what might destroy us they believe
deeply in getting on around other people
they'd much prefer to have civil
relations with someone rather than tell
them frankly what's on their mind they
accept an important role for secrets and
white lies
the romantic is excited by how things
might ideally be and judges what
currently exists in the world by the
standard of a better imagined
alternative most of the time the current
state of things arouses them to intense
disappointment and anger as they
consider the injustice --is
prevarications compromises and timidity
of the powerful they're often furious
with governments and surprised and
outraged by evidence of venal and
self-interested conduct in society for
their part the classical person pays
special attention to what can go wrong
they're very concerned to mitigate the
downside they're aware that most things
could be a lot worse before condemning a
government they consider the standards
of government across history and may
regard a current arrangement as bearable
under the circumstances high ideals make
them nervous
romantics rebel against the ordinary
they're keen on the exotic and the rare
they're anxious about higher things
being put under pressure to become
useful or commercial they want heroism
excitement and an end to boredom
classical people like daily life they're
familiar enough with extremes to welcome
things that are a little boring they can
see the charm of staying home and doing
the laundry both romantic and classical
orientations have important truths to
impart neither is wholly right or wrong
they need to be balanced but because a
good life requires a judicious balance
of both at this point in history when
the spirit of the age is pretty romantic
it might be the classical attitude whose
distinctive claims and wisdom we need to
listen to most intently it's a mode of
approaching life which is ripe for
rediscovery and it can be repeatedly
sampled in the films on this channel
you